الشواطئ التي تحمل روح البلاد
هذا هو الشخص الذي تم التخلي عنه واختطافه وكان دائمًا مغرمًا بها
نينو في هذه المناقشة يجب أن يردد كل شيء
سؤالنا الاستراتيجي الكبير أقوله هنا
جملة مركزية جدًا جدًا، نزل الآن لأننا
يجب علينا إعادة تنظيم التفكير، وليس نحن
سنكون بالتأكيد في ورطة عندما أتصل بشاؤول موفاز
اذهب باسم العديد من العائلات العديدة التي تعتبر والدي
أيها القتيل والمخطوف لا تضع يدك في مجاري الدم
من يغسل عرقنا منذ السابع من أكتوبر عار
أن أيديكم أيضًا ستكون ملطخة بدماء الموتى
وكلهم مقتولين.تم التوقيع على موافقتك على قبول التعيين
أنت أيضا في الفشل والذعر السابع
أكتوبر أنا حقا أطلب منه أن يسحب يده
أن الأشخاص الآخرين لن يمدوا أيديهم إلى اللجنة أيضًا
مرحباً بلجنة تحقيق مغسولة من نوع أو آخر
تكريما لرئيس الأركان، اللواء هرتسي هليفي، هنا ماتان
رغم أنني لست ضابطا، إلا أنني مقاتل في الاحتياط
الذين جندوا في الأسر لشهر أكتوبر مع مئات الآلاف
ووجد المحاربون حتى الآن ما يقرب من 100 يوم
في الاحتياط أريد أن أخبرك شخصيا
وأعتقد أنني أمثل العشرات في هذا البيان
الآلاف من الأصدقاء والمحاربين في تحقيق عملك
تعيين شخص مثل هذا الجنرال آفي فركاش الذي يدعمه
الويل للذين يرفضون كمظهري المسؤولية
على المستوى الوطني، قمت بتعيينه للتحقيق في الجيش الآن
ومن المفترض أن يتم تعيين زهافي فركاش في اللجنة
طالما أنه يوقع تاج الرفض في عيني
من غير المناسب جدًا ألا يكون ذلك هو أن الأصداء تخرج
من اجتماعات المجلس الوزاري المصغر، هلوسة عدم الكلام
أثناء الحرب وماذا يقول القانون عنها
مثل هذه التسريبات من اجتماعات الحكومة يجب أن تنتظر 30
سنة من اجتماعات مجلس الوزراء هي كارثة، وبالتالي في جوهرها
ينبغي الاهتمام بهذا الأمر لأن الوزراء لا يفعلون ذلك
سيكونون قادرين على قول الحقيقة حول هذا السلوك
يجب إيقافه وإذا لزم الأمر جهاز كشف الكذب
يُسمح بإجراء جهاز كشف الكذب في الخزانة بطلب
يتساءل رئيس الأركان عن سبب مجيئه لأنه في النهاية
قائد الجيش هو حكومة إسرائيل، ويجب ألا ننسى ذلك
هذا قائد الجيش وليس وزير الدفاع
رئيس الوزراء هو الحكومة الإسرائيلية بأكملها، نعم الآن
مسموح لهم بطرح الأسئلة ولكن كيف تقول التكفير
يجعل الموسيقى صحيحة ويحتاج إلى التحدث إلى رئيس الأركان
بكل احترام لأن رئيس الأركان يمثل شيئا اسمه مؤسسة
رئيس الأركان إذا بدأنا خلال الحرب
إن بدء القتال مع بعضكم البعض سيكون وضعًا سيئًا
وأقول مرة أخرى أن هذه التسريبات هي تسريبات
التسريبات غير المسؤولة التي تضر بالأمن
الدولة والإضرار بحياة البشر أيضاً، فلا مكان لذلك
ومن ناحية أخرى، هناك أطراف مهتمة تتكرر مراراً وتكراراً
تمرير التفضيلات على هؤلاء الأشخاص من خلال الظهر
سموترتز بن جابر ميري ريجيف لم أقل من
لا أعرف من هم بعضهم، سترون من محادثتي
لقد كنت مستيقظًا جدًا هناك منذ أسبوعين وعادت بالأمس
أعرف عن تهديده منه في محادثة معه
أعرف أن مصادره مدرب سألته
كيف تعرف ما أقوله، ولكن
إنهم خائفون مما إذا بدا أننا قد وصلنا
إلى وضع يمكن فيه بالفعل إنشاء فرق تحقيق
لجان التحقيق في تيحيل ولا شك والحقيقة أن ذلك
بعد فوات الأوان، كان ينبغي أن يتم إنشاؤها في وقت سابق
لذلك قد يقول شخص آخر أن الوقت قد حان أيضًا
إنشاء لجنة التحقيق الحكومية اللازمة
التحقق من اتخاذ القرار على المستوى السياسي وهنا
وكما قلت من قبل سأقول مرة أخرى أن هناك مشكلة خطيرة
في إسرائيل لا يوجد تقليد، وهناك تهرب منهجي
دعونا نسمي هذا الأمر لجميع رؤساء الوزراء، وليس فقط نتنياهو
وأيضا آخرون من لجان التحقيق ذوي الأسنان والشهود
تحقيق الدولة كنت في ملال خلال هذه الفترة
حرب الراهبات الثانية وأولمرت فعل ما في وسعه
من أجل تجنب لجنة تحقيق حكومية اقترح
لجنة تحقيق حكومية ذات صلاحيات أقل
وفُرضت عليه لجنة تحقيق بسبب الضغط الشعبي
نفس الشيء يجب أن يحدث للجنة الدولة الآن
يجب أن يتم فتح تحقيق الدولة الآن، وينبغي أن يحدث ذلك
أن يرأسه قاض أعلى ولا أحد
تمارين أخرى وعليها أن تبدأ في اختبار
إن عمليات صنع القرار على المستوى السياسي واضحة للجميع
الذي كان هناك أمس
في خزانة موس ميرونا ماركوم د